More Sex = Better Health... and 5 Other Medical
Facts
1.
Lyme disease has nothing to do with limes
or limestone, but rather is a bacterial infection.
It is named after a city, Lyme, Connecticut,
where it was first recognized as a distinct
medical disease.
(QF 504)
2.
According to a study published in The British
Medical Journal in 1997 that analyzed just
under 1,000 men from 45-59 years old starting
in 1979, the more frequently a man has sex,
the longer his life expectancy is.
Specifically, men who have sex at least twice
per week were 50% less likely to die during
the scope of the study than those who reported
only having sex about once a month.
Of course, it may simply be that healthier
people are likely to have more sex, but that
isn’t as fun as saying “more sex = longer
life”.
Whatever the case, there does seem to be a
correlation between frequency of sex and life
expectancy in males.
(QF 598)
3.
The small indent, or vertical groove, under
your nose and right above your lips is called
a “philtrum”, as well as a “medial cleft”.
This same vertical groove can be found in
many different types of mammals between their
mouths and their nose.
In human males, those on the autistic spectrum
tend to have much broader philtrums than people
not on the spectrum.
(QF 646)
4.
In ancient times, the root part of the carrot
plant that we eat today was not typically
used.
The carrot plant however was highly valued
due to the medicinal value of its seeds and
leaves.
For instance, Mithridates VI, King of Pontius
(around 100BC) had a recipe for counteracting
certain poisons with the principle ingredient
being carrot seeds.
It has since been proven that this concoction
actually works.
5.
Veins are very close to the surface of skin,
which helps them play a role in heat dissipation.
Due to this closeness to the surface, they
are very visible through the skin.
This near-surface location is largely why
veins often appear blue despite the fact that
the blood running through them is dark red.
Specifically, this is from the way light diffuses
in the skin.
Veins may appear blue from the way subcutaneous
fat absorbs low-frequency light.
This permits only high frequency blue and
violet wavelengths to penetrate through the
skin to the vein, with the other wavelengths
getting filtered off from the pigmentation
of your skin.
In fact, when skin is removed, such as when
dissecting a cadaver, you’ll see the veins
and arteries actually are a somewhat similar
color.
People with extremely light skin, such as
an albino, will typically have veins that
show up as dark purple or dark red, more closely
resembling the actual color of the blood running
through
the veins.